describe your perfect man or why he
should have you
oh it's time with me um
perfect man ideally
six two
a bit
got a bit of weight to him not not I
can't not too skinny funny humble loyal
attentive
um
ambitious and he should want me because
I would
reciprocate the same energy
for me the perfect man would be just
taller than me
um
supportive
ambitious loyal
knows what he wants in life takes care
of the family the home
and yeah he should want me because
I have a really big heart
um funny I think in tune with himself
I.E spiritually
um I'm not really bothered about his
heart to be honest he needs to be more
than average downstairs and also know
how to use it and completely obsessed
with me and ambitious
I just wondered when someone's going to
mention sex because women was going like
sex is not important I mentioned the
Willie side you're the only one that did
because that matters yeah yeah nobody
mentioned money nobody mentioned a job
and she's the only one that mentioned
down and I said I'm ambitious as well so
if he's ambitious he's got pee yeah but
he can be a bin man I want to become a
bigger
real ambition real ambition
that's what I mean when women say
ambition it could be a road sweeper and
then his ambition is to drive the truck
yeah I hear that no
ambition to be you know have businesses
that are successful and you know become
a millionaire if not billionaire
I feel like it's ambition is ambition
obviously in a perfect world he'd be a
good earner but you have but he needs to
be he needs to enjoy what he does for a
living there's no good someone being
rich and is miserable or as rich and
does something they don't want to do
just for the sake of making money would
you would you be okay with a guy that's
an artist but makes 10 pounds an hour
and he's happy with it yeah and he's a
really good artist no that's why I said
yes dude you'd have to make a decent
wage me personally if I feel like
salaries is an important factor you both
have to be heard and you both have to be
bringing something in
would you date someone that makes less
than you
I'm not necessary I don't mind if it's
less as long as it's not like I'm
carrying
them if they're still able to be a
financial support button this doesn't
bother me how much less could he make
than you
thirty percent twenty percent fifty
percent
I mean it depends on what caliber again
as long as it's not gonna financially
you know what you make I mean I'm not
I'm not gonna ask you to say that but
like what percent less so 20 less than
you 10 percent
um yeah well based on my salary then
yeah I'd say no more than no more than
20 no okay what about you
like for me it's very important for like
my man to take care of the household
like the bills electricity all of that
so simple I would prefer if he made more
than me okay do you do you have a
cookbook
of like recipes that you've made
yourself no okay so why why would he pay
a hundred percent of the bills if you
don't have you know no I didn't say 100
of the bills just mostly takes care of
the bills okay so what percent of the
bills yeah like
sixty seventy percent of it seventy
percent okay
um obviously I'm an artist so I aspire
to big things like I want to be a
multi-millionaire so I don't expect my
guy to earn that type of money
um but as long as he's he's really
really trying and he's got his
together and it's fine you want to be a
multi-millionaire how old are you 38.
when do you expect to be a multi-million
in the next two years in the next two
years how are you gonna do that um
through my music creativity yeah okay
I'm gonna do an album so I just you know
are you yeah at some point yeah oh cool
I just wanted to know how to if you're
gonna do it I was like I'll do the same
if you have a plan okay but you what you
do is different to what I do
so what would your album be what would
it consist of I was gonna follow your
plan you're gonna be more okay no don't
follow my plan just do what you want to
do okay okay Auntie do you have any
other questions yeah um
poor man with ambition or rich man with
none
it's a good question
for me it's a rich man with none
because if he's Rich he could we could
be doing other things like going on
holiday creating things and that will
run out if he's got no ambition to make
more money not really because he's not
really he's Rich you can't take that
away from him you can't get it from his
family he's Rich that's what girls
thinking now
it don't change in it he's either Rich
Forever or poor forever that's how it
works so yeah Rich no because it's all
money it can run out if you spend
frivolously and just to start doing
Madness he's going to run out I'd rather
report my ambition because at least I
know he's gonna get somewhere because
he's ambitious if you're rich with no
ambition you're just gonna spank it and
you don't aspire to do anything some
people have wealth generational wealth
that way right now it depends how rich
we're talking it was like really rich
like generational wealth then I don't
see you'd be surprised a lot of
like I come I come from an area where
like there's a lot of wealthy people and
you'd be surprised how quick they can
blow their kids can blow the money you'd
be surprised
but it's like when we get asked a
question is it body money you can't
change it it's just something that's
always the same if he's rich with no
ambition he's Rich it don't matter it's
just right so as long as you've got the
no Ambush I'm with you so he's got money
and he just doesn't want to do anything
I think she thinks because we've done
sure like we've done question have you
seen a show before no I've talked about
a beam of Kings so oh okay yeah because
King and his show he says it doesn't
switch because like that he has a
different question and it doesn't switch
but I think she's saying it could switch
later you just have to pick one on the
starting point
because I find that you find that with
women they always want somebody who's
made it and I think with men they all
the women want to say that they've made
their money before they meet a man or
they want somebody that's made and I
think the most successful relationships
poor men with ambition where they build
together
because you've both grafted together you
come from nothing I've got something and
I think if you look at most of the rich
couples out there the rich man out there
they're built with their woman from
nothing the ones that have it as well if
you meet someone who's already got it
you're just you're replaceable at this
point yeah because he's got access to
however much because that's what he's
used to when you've built with someone
they're gonna have more value for you
because he was there from the beginning
and grafted with them not to say that
they still won't do so they still won't
leave but they'll have more value for
you I think look at the under 50s out
there that are rich
and look at the ones that have made it
together that are in couples that have
built it from nothing can now get in
there and you'll see the difference
that's why I asked the question
because a lot of women they want to
either
get they want to get their own
but you want to be a millionaire in two
years
have you got a man now sorry no I'm
single right so when you're a
millionaired then you're gonna get a man
are you going to get a man before no I'm
not waiting for that like I'm focusing
on my career I've been married I was in
a relationship for 15 years I've got
children so now I need to just focus on
myself and put all my energy into that
whatever comes to me comes to me but I'm
not going to be of a man because of all
his money whatever I'm gonna get my own
which I mean and I would love to share
it with him also I always say that even
if I'm a millionaire I'll give him his
money he still has to pay for the meals
and stuff with regard just because I
like that feeling you master chivalry
are you masculating you can ask her a
question what is it what'd you say
emasculating yeah or demasquerade what
do you mean if you're giving a man money
to pay for your meal that's not
demasculating him how is that that's
good man well if he's got the money and
he wants to pay for it fine if you ain't
got it then I'll give it to you boo we
can pretend like who cares money I want
to know what blessings like because he
might give a different
nah that's just crazy sorry
uh if you're gonna give a guy money for
him to pay like yeah but if I'm a
millionaire and you're on a standard
wage I'm paying for everything that just
makes sense so instead of when we go to
a restaurant and I'm pulling out my
credit card you're gonna pull out the
credit card don't matter where the
money's coming from but it doesn't feel
like a man though yeah
it's just like when you're in the media
and entertainment money's different you
can have a hit and you're going to get
millions of pounds we're not doing a
normal nine to five it's different it's
a different reality it's a guy just as a
man I'd rather take you to McDonald's
that's called eager and pride yeah and
men have a lot of that I know but babe
you know when you're actually dating a
millionaires it will be a different vibe
in a different language that you're
speaking um
I'll be back here in two years and we'll
have a conversation I have to go boo
because I'm going to miss my my train
I'm really sorry I did actually tell the
staff that I need to leave oh okay sorry
I don't want to leave would you guys
stay if you got if we got your yes 100
okay that's fine
the stream's doing well but if if you
have to go
that's perfect thank you guys
Super Chat for the Ubers
um was I gonna ask would you guys go
down in lifestyle for a family
so say
no Nails no hair very little makeup
budget
but you get a man
for a lifetime loyal he's everything you
want but you have to go down in
lifestyle you maybe get what what's you
pick the amount they get a month for
recreational Auntie's better with the
budgeting recreational for them for the
whole household or just for them for
them I think they get to spend on
themselves everything else is the kids
or the family 500 pound a month 500
pounds a month so that's a lot to be
with a perfect man yeah yeah maybe not
pert let's no man's perfect but he does
everything that I need him to do yeah
but you live in where do they live
auntie I think Auntie's going to give
the better picture where do they live
they've been kind in a tablet
I don't really
yeah so you go from you go from say like
a house a big house in like Primrose
Hill
on your own
to go into a tower Block in Canon town
with your perfect man and your perfect
family
but in order to do that don't forget
your building with him
but in order to do that you're not
allowed to no Nails no makeup because
you can't afford it just yet how often
how often can they go out with the girls
you've mentioned going out with girls no
how often can they go out it could be
just like a dinner or like whatever kind
of full dinner you'd invite the girls in
for a night in oh a night and how often
can they do that once a month once a
month yeah so it's either that or I'm
just on my own basis or you go out with
him yeah to be if I'm being completely
honest but he's your perfect man perfect
like you've got two kids perfect I'll be
comfortable like it's not the kids are
paid for it you're the only thing you
can't they can't afford is you're upkeep
I'd rather I'd rather the family to be
honest family wait so I can't get my
hair done
I just would say what makeup nothing
nothing for how long is that like for as
long as it takes for him to get out of
the kids till the kids are let's see 10.
all right I'll say 15. I'll compromise
13. there's no like divorce inside like
this is my perfect match this is you
know I mean
you're still gonna fight you know but
you're still you know human you'll fight
you know now and then but overall a good
man
but yeah for 13 years you can you can't
really go out your friends can only come
to you that's really it
uh I mean I already have my perfect
mindset that mine I don't necessarily
need to do all the hair and nails makeup
because he's already there so I guess I
would take the family and the man yeah
yeah family all day yeah should you wear
makeup for do you make up for yourselves
you do a little bit for yourself or do
you do it to look attractive to men no I
don't do it to attract men or anything I
do it for myself because I do love hair
and makeup and I do love getting my
nails done it just
I'm just used to doing that
you just say yeah
because you wouldn't normally would go
into a club with no makeup on in your
bald head Queen Rose no one's No One's
Gonna Do it when you go out yeah you
dress yourself up to attract the
opposite sex do you do it to feel good
too however you do it for the op for the
opposing person so if I've already got
my man if he accepts me with no wig no
makeup bashes now then I'm good to be
fair yeah exactly that's basically yeah
no makeup on my hair back and stuff like
that I've done it I've done it and I've
just done it because I want to go out
and listen to music I don't care about
being attractive no one because I don't
care I just want to drink and just to
enjoy music so I've done it but then
again I don't wear makeup
we'll get my nails done
you know what somebody needs to give me
a makeover I want one of them big old
wigs I want to get eyelashes I want to
see how different I look I want makeup I
want to get the nails done what do you
think Pearl give me a on makeover an
auntie makeover yeah and yeah anti-anti
makeover Auntie makeover I think we
could do that when uh yeah when Melanie
King comes to town she could Style Both
of Us yeah something
hmm
do you think people do you think
everyone
um
this is another thing I got in trouble
for
they come for me for no reason really
honestly so do you think everyone
deserves love
no no
yeah you think everyone deserves love
yeah what about
Hitler
uh he's going and phase that on your
mother could love you
his own family would as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible